for
for at for people that don't know in
your family
uh because there's an interview that one
of his sons did years ago i think 10
years ago one of
osama bin laden's sons did an interview
while he was still alive saying
uh my father's not even the most
dangerous one he's not even the most
ruthless ones
there's for people that are way more
ruthless than he is
what did you know about the
potential and the vision of your uncle
like what was the vision did you know it
or was it just kind of like a quiet
thing well
you know you don't need to know what
they're up to you don't need to know
what they're doing and your
father kind of defended him meaning
talking to your mother or your father
kind of defended him
what what what vision did you guys have
of who your uncle was
pre-911
so as i mentioned
my mother was very much in the know
in terms of understanding the mentality
of the society but also those who were
extremely devout and practiced
islam in its literal form she was able
to observe
you know such people in saudi arabia and
the fact that
you know there was the divorce the
separation and the divorce case and the
background and
she was obviously looking out for her
three girls you know it was just the
four
of us in the west with this
in this very strange situation and you
know
my mother always looked out for us
and following the events
you know the 1993 well from you know
when uh
osama uh went to afghanistan and
his activities in the 80s and then in
1993 the first
bombings in the basement of the world
trade center
and then the 1998 bombings in the
embassies in
kenya and tanzania so she she'd been
following this
very closely because she knew that it
wasn't going to stop
even though she didn't know obviously
the plans um
or what was going to happen but she knew
that he was never going to stop and
she was very fearful for the
consequences that that could have
for me and my two older sisters
considering the name that we carry
and as you said
you know osama bin laden
is one of thousands
of very radical or
i would call them literal muslims
the muslims who really believe in a
literal application of the ideology
and my mother again you know alludes to
this or
not eludes but you know pinpoints it in
her
in her book especially in the final
chapters where she calls them you know
the
army of shadows because there are so
many and she was actually
you know one of the first to make this
analogy of you know if you take the
whole muslim
population which at the time you know
was
one one billion or so and you take ten
percent
and you take the ten percent of these
ten percent of the more you know devout
ones and then you arrive at a number if
you take
the ones that are willing to commit
these atrocious atrocious
crimes and um killing themselves even
themselves in the process
for their uh beliefs you know you arrive
at a number which is over a million
people
which is non-negligible obviously
and sadly everything that my mother
predicted in the book you know warning
where she warned the west
of this army of shadows and how they
were infiltrating our society
tragically it has come to pass and we're
living with the consequences
here in the west ever since i mean i'm
based in europe
and the climate here
is extremely tense
whether you're in france or in germany
in sweden
in in the netherlands
austria the
the amounts of you know attacks it's
just relentless you know in france the
past month has been you know
absolute bloodshed and um
and the media doesn't really you know
for 20 years the media didn't really
talk about it or covered it up and
you had some brave brave voices who
called it out you know including my
mother
saying you know that this is a real
problem this ideology is a real
problem and in the meantime we were
watching
the news and looking at the press and
some politicians
saying that you know islam is a religion
of peace perpetrating that narrative
as opposed to you know in french there's
a there's this expression
calling a cat a cat you know naming
something
what it is what it is right and um
the situation here is is quite bleak i
mean
not to sound negative or pessimistic i'm
quite an
optimistic person but the reality the
reality here in europe and
you know people don't want to talk about
this because apparently you get labeled
as a racist
if you say these things but just the
mere demographics
here in europe the landscape in the next
30 40 50 years
will be very different to the europe
that we know
that we know today and
nobody is really talking about this but
it's something we really need to look at
for the sake of our future generations
here in europe there's a lot of by the
way when you said the
the muslim is a religion of peace that
politician you mentioned is
a president he's a two-term president
that you were mentioning i believe you
were
there are two presidents there's george
bush who said that
there's barack obama who said that
and um the whole press
the mainstream media all of the
mainstream media
perpetrated that narrative um
for the past you know 20 years
what's what's important do you follow
bill maher
do you follow bill maher at all or no
yes
the one thing impressive about bill
maher is when he came down to even
though he's a very very
uh far left uh uh uh democrat himself
he he was not on in the same camp as the
rest of them when it came down to the
topic of islam but let me get back to a
couple things you said the
the army of shadow if you take one
percent of the billion
uh muslims at the time that's 10 million
you take 10
of them that's 1 million that's 1
million that's willing to go
to extreme measures to do whatever they
can to represent their religion
religion which makes me think because i
grew up in iran i lived in around 10
years so
i'm one that escaped iran and went to a
refugee camp in germany so i remember
what it was like as a kid growing up
[Music]
there